Ralph breaks the Internet is like an
Easter egg hunt on a lawn made out of
Easter eggs with references to pop
culture of the past baked into the
movies very DNA you've already seen the
wreck-it ralph sequel at least once here
are a few callbacks and inside jokes you
might have missed Ralph breaks the
internet doesn't spend much time on
human characters beyond a few anonymous
gamers and Internet users this movie is
solely focused on its digital creations
creatures of the arcade cabinet or the
world wide web any other approach would
take precious screen time away from the
denizens of Tepper there are still a few
moments where the movie checks in with
people on the other side of the monitor
if you noticed any conspicuous cutaways
to carbon-based life forms you are
probably noticing some of the movies
cast of real youtubers and internet
personalities among the stars making an
appearance are comedian colleen
ballinger
known for her character Miranda sings
actress Danny Fernandez comedian Flula
Borg and streamer Tiffany Herrera
better known as cupcake Ralph breaks the
internet also includes another nod to
online video culture with the YouTube
play button visible in the office of yes
a personified algorithm who runs the
show at buzz - if you aren't familiar
YouTube's play buttons are real-life
physical plaques that the company gifts
out to content creators for passing
milestones in their subscriber count
there's a silver button for channels
that exceed a hundred thousand
subscribers a gold button for those that
pass a million and a diamond button for
those that go past ten million the one
in the background of the Ralph's sequel
looks like a gold one indicating that
the fictional content company still has
a way to go before it gets to the top of
the heap it's no surprise that there's
an entire galaxy of references to the
Star Wars universe and Ralph breaks the
internet particularly once Ralph and
vanellope make their way to Disney
property there are obvious drop ins like
stormtrooper security guards and a cameo
from c-3po but there are also smaller
touches that are connected see far far
away a couple of examples include an
r2d2 themed tie on one of the office
workers killing time by sharing Ralph's
viral videos you can also see some
collectible looking Star Wars themed
plates on display in mr. lit wax office
Ralph goes through a few options while
trying to come up with content for his
viral video scheme what
trends should he be chasing well there
are screaming goat videos which are back
in style as well as bee pun that never
go out of style but there's also a clip
from the mega popular video game
fortnight briefly focusing on the
floating battle bus full of players that
kicks off every Battle Royale if that
wasn't enough the movie also shows Ralph
indulging in a bonafide fortnight dance
specifically the floss we hope you
thanked the bus driver for this
experience on your way home from the
theater while wreck-it Ralph presented a
Toy Story ask look at what happens at
the arcade when no one's looking Ralph
breaks the internet takes its heroes to
the sprawling metropolis of the World
Wide Web
in that sense the sequel has less in
common with Toy Story and more in common
with Zootopia the 2016 Disney animated
feature about a vibrant city in the
animal kingdom the most obvious Easter
Egg is an appearance from shady
protagonist Nick Wilde who appears near
Disney section of the Internet but a
smaller reference to Zootopia can be
found in the online game slaughter race
as evidenced by a sign for the mr. big
limo service the fact that the
references in slaughter race raises some
head scratching questions though as
Zootopia turned into an apocalyptic
urban battlefield or de slaughter race
just have a gritty Zootopia level either
way it's no version of the city we'd
want to see Judy Hopps have to deal with
during Ralph and vanellope 's first
visit to ebay the two are presented with
rows of different kiosks each auctioning
off some peculiar item most of the stuff
isn't worth much but at least one item
in the auction house is treasure
straight out of the Disney Vault
in the background viewers can see the
magic Genie summoning lamp from Aladdin
up for bidding we're not actually sure
if the genie himself would be included
interestingly Aladdin's Jasmine can
later be seen wielding her own magic
lamp as a weapon when vanellope intrudes
on the princess lounge maybe they're
more common than we thought after Ralph
and vanellope arrived at the oh my
Disney corner of the Internet they
literally bump into a dearly departed
icon of comic books and pop culture
while the final version of the Cameo is
just a quick reveal of Stanley turning
around to look toward the camera after
vanellope knocks into him the surprising
appearance wasn't initially meant to
so fleeting originally Lee's cameo was
going to be a more involved sequence
co-director Phil Johnston explained the
details to the rap saying we had this
thing called marvel eyes yourself where
the human avatar is able to go through
what looks like a metal detector and
turned into a Marvel character and as
part of that scene we had Stanley go
through the Marvel Iser
but when we decided to lose that joke we
still wanted to have Stanley in the
movie because we loved Stanley in case
you missed it Ralph breaks the internet
also features two post-credit sequences
one an extended riff on the Disney
Princesses scene makes its appearance
halfway through the credits but another
more involved sequence doesn't kick in
until the very end of the movie and it's
an emotional roller coaster to say the
least
the final moments of the movie are
disguised as a sneak peak for Disney's
hotly anticipated frozen sequel just as
the sneak peak seems to be getting off
the ground the first look is abruptly
cut off by Ralph in the vein of a
classic rick roll a vintage internet gag
centering on Rick Astley's never going
to give you up it's a move that shows
some real moxie teasing younger frozen
fans with an ice-cold joke that only
their parents are probably going to get
it just goes to show you the Internet
can be kind of a cruel place
[Music]